Si lo miramos con cierta perspectiva, Latinoamérica
es una especie de péndulo ideológico entre
polos opuestos:
Desde las dictaduras militares de los 70s
y los 80s, hasta la transición a la democracia,
la lluvía de privatizaciones y la liberalización
económica de los 90s, o el estatismo todopoderoso
del conocido como socialismo del siglo XXI.
Casi que podríamos decir que América Latina
todo es… o blanco, o negro.
El asalto de los partidarios de Bolsonaro
al Congreso, a la Corte Suprema y al Palacio
de Planalto, sede de la Presidencia, ha sido
el último ejemplo de esta furia pasional
que frecuentemente resulta tan difícil de
hacer compatible con el ordenado funcionamiento
del marco democrático.
[Una furia además que siempre, siempre está
dominada por ciertos parámetros comunes que
creo todos conocemos perfectamente.]
Pero…
¿Y si en cierta forma y a pesar de los recientes
acontecimientos este péndulo realmente se
estuviera comenzando a resquebrajar?
¿Puede estar América Latina ante un punto
de inflexión ideológica?
¡Arranquemos!
[Por cierto, hablando de puntos de inflexión…
La guerra de Ucrania ha cambiado por completo.
Las tornas se han invertido.
Ahora es el ejército ucraniano quien lleva
la iniciativa en el campo de batalla mientras
las fuerzas rusas no paran de sumar nuevos
fracasos.
Sin embargo, el frente militar no es el único
campo de batalla.
La guerra económica también juega un papel
clave, especialmente para la capacidad de
resistencia de Ucrania.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Cómo está evolucionando
está guerra económica?
No te pierdas el último vídeo de Si lo Hubiera
Sabido, el canal de información financiera
de Mutuactivos dónde te cuentan todos los
detalles.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto, ahora sí, comencemos.
Los primeros 10 años del siglo XXI sumergieron
de lleno a prácticamente toda la región
en lo que diferentes analistas políticos
calificaron como la “marea roja” .
En marzo de 2005, por ejemplo, se estimaba
que el 75% de los 350 millones de habitantes
de América Latina estaban gobernados por
partidos de izquierda.
En aquella época podemos recordar a Hugo
Chavez, Daniel Ortega, Lula da
Silva, Rafael Correa, Evo Morales y la familia
Kirchner haciendo numerosas reformas
económicas y sociales para acercarse al socialismo
y nutrir al Estado con cada vez más instrumentos
intervencionistas…
Y, ojo, no solo hablo del terreno económico.
Lo de Caracas y Managua ya sabemos que fue
mucho más allá de las cuentas públicas.
(“Desde Ecuador decía Bolívar, o nos unimos
de verdad o un nuevo coloniaje legaremos a
la posteridad.
El banco del sur, la telesur, una televisora
del sur, una petrosur, la unidad energética
del sur…
Hugo Chavez Frias)
[Y eso por no hablar del propio asalto a la
democracia]
En aquella vorágine de entusiasmo socialista
se generaron plataformas multilaterales,
como la Unión de Naciones Suramericanas (UNASUR),
la Comunidad de Estados
Latinoamericanos y Caribeños (CELAC) o la
Alianza Bolivariana para los Pueblos de
Nuestra América (ALBA), ¡Vamos!
que el proceso parecía del todo imparable,
pero…
Un momento, porque sin embargo, la corrupción
y el voto popular - allí donde se respetó,
claro está - comenzaron a romper una por
unas las olas de toda esa inmensa marea roja.
Fijaos.
N1(24 de noviembre de 2015: Macri gana en
Argentina y pone fin al kirchnerismo tras
12 años.
El País)
N2(7 de diciembre de 2015: La oposición venezolana
obtiene mayor número de escaños y controlará
la Asamblea Nacional.
CNN)
N3(31 agosto de 2016: Impeachment: Dilma Rousseff
es destituida como presidenta de Brasil.
BBC)
N4(5 de febrero de 2018: Lenín Moreno bloquea
a Rafael Correa: Ecuador vota en referéndum
a favor de limitar a dos periodos el mandato
presidencial.
BBC)
N5(28 de octubre de 2018: Bolsonaro es electo
presidente de Brasil.
DW)
Ya lo veis, el giro que la región pegó desde
el año 2015 generó un escenario totalmente
contrario a la marea roja…
Cuyas fuerzas quedaron muy debilitadas…
Aunque no derrotadas.
La victoria de Lopez Obrador en México, seguida
de la derrota de Mauricio Macri en 2019, a
la par de las revueltas sociales en Chile
y el regreso del partido de Evo Morales al
poder en Bolivia en 2020, volvieron a patear
el tablero político latinoamericano..
Otra vez, pero, ahora bien, ¿fue esta sucesión
de hechos un remake de la marea roja?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1(LA DEBACLE DEL RECAMBIO POLÍTICO)
En julio de 2018, cuando el 53.19% de los
mexicanos llevaron a Andrés Manuel López
Obrador, AMLO, a la presidencia, no sólo
rompieron con la hegemonía del PRI -que tan
apenas había sido brevemente erosionada por
el PAN - en el país, sino que dieron la primera
campanada del cambio que se avecinaba.
Y es que, a pesar de que AMLO tuvo que convivir
como un lobo solitario un tiempo, acompañado
por presidentes disidentes al socialismo como
Piñera en Chile, Bolsonaro en Brasil, Duque
en Colombia o Macri en Argentina, el estallido
social en Chile y Ecuador en 2019 terminarían
por abrir de nuevo la caja de pandora en la
región:
“A todos los chilenos, ellos están en guerra
contra todos los chilenos de buena voluntad
que queremos vivir en democracia, con libertad
y en paz”.
Sebastían Piñera)
(La ola de disturbios en Santiago que terminó
provocando, incluso, el inicio de un proceso
constituyente, fue posiblemente un shock tremendamente
traumático para los países contrarios a
la marea roja: hasta ese mo mento el modelo
chileno había servido como un ejemplo de
estabilidad y crecimiento gracias a sus políticas
más orientadas al mercado.
Sin embargo, tras los disturbios esa idea,
ese modelo empezó a dejar de ser un objetivo
para convertirse en un mito con un alto coste
político.)
[Sí ese era el resultado…
Quien iba querer replicar el modelo.]
¿Y sabéis qué?
Fue justo entonces cuando desde Caracas, los
melancólicos custodios del conocido como
socialismo del Siglo XXI comenzaron a vaticinar
un huracán ideológico que volvería a posicionar
- otra vez - a la izquierda en lo más alto
del poder político.
“Está soplando una brisa bolivariana, está
soplando una brisa bolivaria que va a venir
desde el río grande y un poquito más arriba
hasta la Patagonia.
Brisa bolivariana, brisa de los pueblos libertarios”.
Diosdado Cabello, vicepresidente del Partido
Socialista Unido de Venezuela)
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que esta vez la
historia fue muy diferente.
Al menos muy diferente de lo que los Maduros,
Cabellos y compañía tenían en mente.
Aquellos estallidos de violencia no hicieron
que la sociedad reclamase el regreso de los
referentes y los custodios de la marea roja,
sino que, en cambio, generaron resultados…
un tanto aguados.
Ni para unos ni para otros.
(UN ROJO QUE DESTIÑE)
Si vemos la tendencia de los gobiernos más
destacados de Latinoamérica en el año 2019,
podemos constatar que la izquierda había
sido diezmada del mapa político de la región,
salvo por algunos casos concretos, como México,
Nicaragua, Cuba y Venezuela.
(Sin embbargo, unos tres años después, la
brisa bolivariana parece haber hecho su trabajo
con cambiazos tan llamativos como los que
se han dado incluso en bastiones del centro-derecha
latinoamericano como Colombia)
Si tenemos en cu enta el mapa…
No se, parece bastante claro…
Podemos decir que la marea roja está de vuelta,
que el socialismo del siglo XXI se ha hecho
de nuevo con el poder, otra vez la revolución
bolivariana vuelve a marcar la música a seguir…
¿Verdad?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que no.
Sí, los partidos de izquierdas, en ocasiones
partidos y movimientos muy vinculados a la
vieja guardia bolivariana, se han hecho de
nuevo con el poder…
Sin embargo, un momento, porque lo cierto
es que el perfil de la mayoría de los actuales
líderes parece muy lejos de lo que en su
día hubieran defendido los Chavez, Castro,
Ortega y compañía.
¿No me creéis?
Pues…
Fijaos.
“Por 104 votos a favor, 18 en contra y 24
abstenciones, la cámara aprobó una resolución
que respalda las declaraciones (de condena)
del presidente Gabriel Boric respecto a los
regimenes dictatoriales de Venezuela, Nicaragua
y Cuba)
“¿De qué yo soy como Hugo Chavez?
Es una calumnia.)
“Chávez, digamos, hizo una promesa a su
sociedad de una distribución social de la
renta petrolera que es de lo que viven los
venezolanos.
El pueblo votó por él varias veces pero
la promesa quedó incumplida, ¿En qué sentido?
En que realmente no se puede construir una
equidad social, una justicia social en una
economía que solo extrae petróleo.)
“A mi me gustaría para Venezuela lo que
yo quiero para Brasil.
Yo quiero que las elecciones sean cada vez
más libres, que se acaten los resultados”.)
N6(28 de enero de 2022: Con apoyo argentino,
la ONU vuelve a condenar al régimen de Maduro
en Venezuela.
La Nación)
Es decir, la región giró a la izquierda,
eso es innegable, sin embargo, esa izquierda
parece algo diferente a la que protagonizó
el comienzo del siglo.
No parece ni de lejos esa izquierda revolucionaria
que estaba enamorada de los largos discursos
de Hugo Chavez.
Los nuevos gobiernos encarnan algo así como
una especie de socialismo latinoamericano
diluido, quizás incluso como una especie
de socialdemocracia latina.
Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Nos pueden gustar más o menos estas corrientes
políticas…
Pero no creo que haya muchas dudas respecto
a que parecen mucho mejor - en todos los aspectos
- que los movimientos revolucionarios de principio
siglo.
Por lo general los nuevos gobiernos no hablan
de revoluciones, expropiaciones, nacionalizaciones
ni cosas por el estilo.
Y eso, pues parece un avance, porque a la
larga puede generar mucha más estabilidad.
Insisto, incluso, aunque no nos gusten sus
políticas el cambio de cromos parece menos
radical.
Incluso Lula ha ganado las elecciones en Brasil
con un ticket electoral que tiene como compañero
de fórmula a Geraldo Alckmin, un referente
del centro-derecha brasileño y un antiguo
contrincante electoral del propio Lula.
Quizás, de alguna forma, Petro siga siendo
en parte la única excepción…
Parece sentirse demasiado cómodo con tiranos
como Maduro…
Pero, incluso, en Colombia la realidad política
bajo Petro no tiene nada que ver con lo que
fueron la mayoría de los movimientos de izquierda
latinoamericanos durante comienzos del s.XXI.
Y la pregunta es, ¿a qué se debe este repentino
cambio?
¿Es una cuestión generacional?
¿Es fruto de la autocrítica de la izquierda
latinoamericana?
¿Es por querer emular a los países europeos?
Pues quizás sea un poco de todo…
Claro que otro factor que puede haber contribuido
a esta pérdida de influencia quizás sea
el financiero.
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado bien.
Atentos.
T3(YA NO HAY QUIEN PAGUE LA FIESTA)
Queridos amigos, amigas, la marea roja de
principio de ciclo tenía un epicentro: Caracas.
Desde la capital venezolana, Hugo Chavez se
posicionaba como un referente político, pero
también financiero, especialmente para todos
los aventureros de la época.
Fijaos.
N7(4 de enero del 2006: Evo Morales se suma
al proyecto antineoliberal y antiimperialista
de Chávez en su visita a Venezuela.
Uno de los convenios firmados serán los 30
millones de dólares que Chávez se ha comprometido
a entregar a Bolivia para obras sociales,
además de suministrar todo el combustible
que consume Bolivia.
El Mundo)
N8(17 de febrero de 2006: Venezuela disfruta
de su bonanza petrolera.
Los expertos creen que el presidente Chávez
ha gastado unos 5.000 millones de dólares
en empresas energéticas fuera de Venezuela,
incluidas refinerías de petróleo nuevas
o de operación conjunta en Cuba, Uruguay
y Brasil.
BBC)
N9(22 de noviembre del 2007: Venezuela sigue
acaparando deuda argentina.
Infobae)
N10(29 de septiembre de 2009: Ecuador acepta
la donación de seis cazas de Venezuela.
El País)
N11(16 de abril del 2008: Venezuela oficializa
acuerdos de suministro crudo Bolivia, Haití
y Nicaragua Venezuela oficializó tres acuerdos
de suministro directo de crudo, por un total
de 1,48 millones de barriles mensuales, a
Bolivia, Nicaragua y Haití, en condiciones
especiales de pago que incluyen intereses
del dos por ciento anual.
El Economista)
Ya lo veis, la tarjeta de crédito hacía
pagos por aquí y por allá como si no hubiera
mañana.
Y por supuesto también financiaba a todo
tipo de movimientos políticos muy radicalizados
de izquierdas.
Todo esto contribuyó a reunir a un púlpito
de gobiernos alrededor de aquel utópico proyecto
de la “Patria Grande”... o mejor dicho,
la “Chequera Grande”.
Pero si todo esto ocurría de manera oficial,
por debajo de la mesa se estima que la
asistencia del chavismo a sus aliados era
más compleja.
El caso más emblemático sería el de Antonini
Wilson, quien reconoció, tras ser capturado
en Buenos Aires, llevar cerca de 800.000 dólares
de PDVSA para financiar la campaña de Cristina
Kirchner en 2007:
(AUDIO8: “ Periodista: ¿De quién era el
dinero le pregunto otra vez?
Guido Antonini Wilson: El dinero era de PDVSA,
de Venezuela
Periodista ¿Y hacia dónde iba el dinero?
Guido Antonini Wilson: El dinero iba para
la campaña presidencial de la actual presidente
Cristina de Kirchner.
Guido Antonini Wilson, testigo del escándalo
del maletín.)
Y es que claro, si la fiesta salía gratis…
¿Por qué no sumarse?
Eso es lo que debieron de pensar muchos líderes
políticos de primera, segunda y tercera fila
de la región…
Que ahora se han cambiado de chaqueta.
Además está claro que los que cogían el
dinero e invitaban a las copas eran los más
populares de la clase.
Sin embargo, hoy las cosas son completamente
distintas.
(La Venezuela de hoy está prácticamente
quebrada, sin posibilidades de respaldar económicamente
ningún proyecto político relevante.
El descalabro de las cuentas públicas producto
de la compulsiva nacionalización de las industrias
privadas, y la falta de inversión en materia
de infraestructura petrolera, ha hecho que
Venezuela no sea capaz siquiera de extraer
su propio petróleo.
Y eso hablando de un país que tiene las mayores
reservas de crudo convencional del mundo…
Es de suspenso mayúsculo.)
Claro, cuándo tienes las arcas llenas te
puedes dar todo tipo de caprichos…
Pero cuándo están vacías eso ya es otra
historia.
Pero…
Sigamos.
T4 (UNA IZQUIERDA CADA VEZ MÁS LIMITADA)
Si volvemos al mapa político de 2022 es evidente
que los signos políticos han cambiado
hacia la izquierda, pero como ya hemos dicho,
los referentes que han llegado al poder son
algo distintos, o al menos han cambiado, respecto
a lo que era la norma habitual en la primera
década del siglo XXI.
Ahora mantienen discursos más moderados y
no dudan en enarbolar la bandera de la tercera
vía.
[Lo que, insisto, no quiere decir que su proyecto
político tenga que resultarnos atractivo…
Eso ya dependerá de cada cuál]
Y además las sociedades parecen también
más críticas…
La derrota del referéndum sobre la nueva
Constitución en Chile, la victoria de las
reformas de Lacalle Pou, el cambio de signo
político que parece que se avecina en la
Argentina…
Los nuevos líderes de izquierdas, o centro-izquierda,
no sólo no están viviendo una luna de miel,
sino que en muchos casos están perdiendo
muchas de sus grandes batallas políticas.
Y eso a pesar de haberse moderado por el camino.
Y por todo eso decimos que el histórico péndulo
de la política latinoamericana puede haberse
roto.
Claro que, quizás pensar latinoamérica en
una función izquierda-derecha puede ser algo
anticuado.
En los últimos años la región parece haberse
acercado a una dinámica más de tipo populismo-antipopulismo,
ante el fracaso de los personalismos de Cristina
Fernandez, Evo Morales o Rafael Correa.
Sea como sea, por todo esto quizás la ola
haya dejado de ser estrictamente roja, para
ser algo más rosada.
Y en cualquier caso, este 2023 viene con una
agenda más que movida para reconocer cuál
será el nuevo péndulo político que marcará
el ritmo en la región:
Guillermo Lasso enfrentará un Referéndum
en febrero, donde someterá los pilares de
su
programa de gobierno al voto popular, buscando
-al estilo de Lacalle Pou- empoderar su
gestión el resto del mandato.
Por su parte, Guatemala, Paraguay y Argentina
tendrán que renovar sus ejecutivos, mientras
que Petro tendrá en las elecciones regionales
de octubre su primer test electoral como presidente.
Luego, la feroz lucha interna del oficialismo
en Bolivia y la crisis institucional de Perú
siembra de interrogantes el porvenir de dichas
naciones, mientras que el desarrollo del gobierno
de Lula en Brasil será clave para entender
hacía dónde se mueve la izquierda latinoamericana:
¿Será está cada vez más rosa?
Te guste más o te gusten menos este tipo
de movimientos, creo que la inmensa mayoría
podemos coincidir que sería una buena noticia…
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta el historial
de esta región.
Claro que con América Latina nunca se sabe…
Pero sea como sea llegados hasta aquí, turno
para ti:
¿Qué piensas sobre la ola rosa que actualmente
atañe la región?
¿Crees que el proyecto del socialismo del
siglo XXI ya quedó descartado o puede resurgir?
¿Está la izquierda latinoamericana renovándose,
o solo guardan las apariencias?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestros comentarios
y abramos debate.
Por supuesto si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias una vez más por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.